are you ready Ryan ready Tom go get the
fat nipples off of Batman remember just
two at a time they are very delicate
nipples George will you especially oh he
seems to like that he has a nice little
smile there val kilmer
i can't tell his acting range is kind of
limited that or just as what's a too big
I can't see any expression oh hey look
at you actually as a blueblood I never
knew that we were actually gonna take
those nipples and give him the Joe
Schumacher in his bed in the middle of
the night I don't have be a nightmare a
dream come true for him why does he have
one on his shoulder
why was Schumacher do that you know I
don't want to the answer that I do not
want to know the answer to that do we
have a winner we have a winner Tom
that's right that's the way we do things
here at pop quiz hotshot I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and ever since I was a
child I always want to play games
quoting movies and TV with my friends
the only problem was I had no friends
well now that I have power I can take my
friends by force with the help of my new
pal general anaesthetic
I can kidnap all the friends I want and
force them to answer questions it might
say by the Bell style sent there will be
last trivia those disturbing cartoons
that give you night terrors but most of
all there will be fun the laughter and
joy will last however long I want heads
up America or this is pop quiz hotshot
and on bag of general anesthetic there
you go
welcome my friends to pop quiz hotshot
you are my friends aren't you yes just
not also do something terrible T there
you go there you go yes you know I I
gotta say I don't usually do this I
don't usually kidnap people and hold
them against their will but you know I
just gotta say ever since I was a child
well I think nostalgia I think happy
thought though I think a childhood this
little nerve goes off cuz I didn't have
that many friends but you're my friends
now yes yes you are and that just makes
me so have because this is what friends
do please please stand up you have a gun
pointing at you yes not very wise but
this is what friends do they get
together and they play games and they
talk and they punish one another they
don't do what the important one is
saying so I just want to say thank you
so very much and we're just gonna have
so much fun right help I'll take that as
a yes Ryan upon interrogation I see our
little chat you said that you do a very
good Popeye impression well I am what I
am that's all the time and it also says
that you want going to radio
broadcasting do you want to go into it
as Popeye well we I do work as an
engineer for our Popeye radio broadcasts
we do for the Popeye fan club and every
year on the weekend after Labor Day
there's a three-day Popeye festival in
Chester Illinois the creator's hometown
and we have a live radio broadcast in
character voice and I am the broadcast
engineer for that somewhere this got
switched around cuz you should clearly
be kidnapping me I've never heard of
Popeye fan more dedicated and scary but
good for you man nicely done nicely done
no problem Tom it says here that when
you were born your doctor was dr. pepper
yes and my last name is beverage and no
one ever it's spelled differently but no
one ever believes that how do you spell
beverage different
you our idge you know I'm glad I
kidnapped you too because clearly you
would be kidnapping other people with
stories like this but nevertheless you
are my friends and I am happy to have
you I hope one of you gets out here
alive at least one but you're not gonna
figure out how to do any of that unless
we go over the rules general anaesthetic
what are the rules each contestant is
asked a series of questions involving
the size of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the Nostalgia Critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes get even harder the winner with
the most points face off against the
nostalgia critic and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
all right are you ready
I don't care here we go Tom which Tim
Burton film featured the lyric just
because I cannot see it doesn't mean I
can't believe it I am here before
Christmas yes Ryan in Fight Club what
are the first two rules of Fight Club
you don't talk about Fight Club and no
the second one really really you are
gonna punch yourself in the face when
you hear that the second rule is you
don't talk about Fight Club yeah nicely
done if I could deduct points from you
actually I can can we do anything - no
we did that's too expensive
okay nevertheless we will still keep
going forward Tom finish this Wonder
Years theme lyric what would you do if I
say out-of-tune yes would you stand up
and walk out okay okay okay don't meet
your life story it's on my iPod
good for you you want cookie ryan in the
avengers what characters said we have a
Hulk Iron Man yes Tom in which Monty
Python film did John Cleese shout I say
you're the Messiah Lord and I should
know I follow a few Life of Brian yes
that was a tough one Ryan finished this
Kevin Spacey line the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was you're tearing me
apart devil
good guess and you know what let me give
it to him because that movie would have
been so much better if they'd have that
like nicely done Tom in the movie frozen
what does Elsa say at the end of the
song let it go the cold never bothered
me anyway
I give you credit for not gouging your
eyes out having to say those words I
definitely give you credit by every rule
would be proud if he or she ever sees
you again Brian in what movie can you
find the line nobody puts Baby in a
corner
Dirty Dancing yes Tom finish this
Simpsons back-and-forth routine from
inside homers head dental plan Lisa
needs braces
yes Ryan in True Lies when Jamie Lee
Curtis asked our own schwarzenegger if
he's ever killed anyone what was his
reply what's for breakfast and that you
are wrong you are wrong that is not it
it actually was yes but they were all
bad Tom what Tarantino movie had the
line all right Ramblers let's get
ramblin Reservoir Dogs yes the Tarantino
film now is the center of a Tarantino
film even before he became Tarantino
Ryan in Being John Malkovich which
characters said I have seen a world that
no man should see Santa Christ
you know I like you I like you because I
really want to punish you for getting
this one wrong in the movie Being John
Malkovich it was John Malkovich who said
man that's a movie where literally
everyone becomes John Malkovich and it's
the most obvious answer in the world but
I didn't see Santa Cruz coming so I'm
gonna give you the ten points for that
oh I've seen Santa Christ coming and I'm
still in therapy I am so shocked dude
and kidnapped me Tom
finish this line from The Truman Show
good morning and in case I don't see ya
good night no good afternoon good
evening and good night Ryan in what
action film de Steve Buscemi say define
irony a bunch of idiots dancing on a
plane to a song they famous by a band
that died in a plane crash Wizard of Oz
the movie would have been a lot better
if he wasn't it but no that was actually
Conair the prequel to Armageddon Tom
didn't what movie has to lie take the
gun
leave the cannoli jingle all the way
very very good guest that was actually
was put the cannoli down no Ryan what
Jack Nicholson film features the line
you make me want to be a better man the
bucket list no actually it was Batman it
was just cut from the final scene and
man it was a totally different movie
with that line no actually it was as
good as it gets
Tom in American Beauty which actor said
look at me jerking off in the shower
this will be the high point of my day
it's all downhill from here
and it's been every day of his since
Kevin Spacey Wow what Kevin Spacey hate
from you man I'm not really I love the
guy oh you do like him all right why
don't you saying that about Kevin Spacey
cuz it's true Wow allegedly
was really seek aid no no I will not
have that about my beloved Kevin Spacey
even though I don't like him Ryan
finished this Will Smith line from men
in black you know what the difference is
between you and me I make this you make
me want to scream again a very different
movie if you would have said that but no
it was actually I make this look good
tom which movie had Kathy Bates saying
I'm your number one fan misery yes Jesus
Christ
okay that was of course the spaz attack
you wouldn't know that because this is
the first episode but nevertheless that
is what it is and Tom appears has
avoided the spaz attack by hitting the
buzzer well done because of that Ryan
you must pay the penalty it is a penalty
of my choice and I say you have to dress
up and talk like Popeye for round two
well just like every other day then the
amount of fear you're filling me with is
delightful
so while you get in the costume Tom you
get to watch our spazzy cartoon that was
that was harsh enough unless you the
spaz 'yes again but we are back and we
buy we're at the beginning of round 2
where Ryan is now in his penalty costume
you look kind of like a sideways Donald
Duck but nevertheless I think I'll work
okay and we are beginning round two
round two actually has tougher questions
so you're gonna have to up the Popeye
voice even more to appease me well I
think I can do that yeah shouldn't be a
problem young fella you don't care like
a pop I like you're hitting on me a
little bit which I'm totally fine with
Emma Gemini the stockholm see this is
round two a pop quiz hotshot here we go
Ryan
name the Star Wars character who said
it's an older code sir but it checks out
L mean when can L be know is actually an
opiate and I just like the fact that
somebody decided hey you know this
character's name should be P it Tom in
Monty Python and the Holy Grail brother
Maynard says of the Holy Hand Grenade
and the number of the counting shall be
what 3 very good Ryan it's the line
nobody's perfect was spoken to Jack
Lemmon at the end of what 1959 comedy
classic Sam I get that well the way
you're dressed I would say that's just a
common phrase you say but yes you were
also corrected Tom finish this line from
dr. Strangelove gentlemen you can't
fight in here this is the war room very
good Brian
in what movie did a kid on a bike for
Peter Lee say I want my $2.00 Sophie's
Choice clothes a similar idea is called
better off dead
name the Christopher Nolan film that had
the line I can't remember to forget you
I wasn't to say the prestige buy my
shirt that's funny or true film so after
that you're right let me try that again
okay okay I'll go I'll go
there's a man with a gun right next to
you right now don't you're married I got
nothing else to live for
give them the ten points just based on
that cuz you know what if he gets out
his wife is gonna kill him any with that
airs I am Ryan what Steven Spielberg
movie had the line we seem to have
reached the age where life stops giving
us things and starts taking them away
Batman Begins the classic Steven
Spielberg hey you know what yeah I gave
him the point for that
I just love confusing Christopher
Nolan's teens feel great they're just so
similar it's understandable for getting
that one from king of the crystal doll
so it is not surprising at all Tom what
British actor said life is pain princess
anyone else is trying to show you
something and that is okay you got the
line who's the actor Cary Elwes what
okay let's go over this together okay
Walsh British actors if Mike is paying
princess Carrie Oh nicely done nicely
done I haven't taken your eyes yet Ryan
what early Zucker Brothers film had the
line this is not Asha Wade we need total
concentration the Kentucky Fried movie
yes oh my god how do you know that movie
let me give you a hug that's just
amazing I love that film you're gonna
win you're gonna win I made my wife
watch the JFK game in that he said it
first
Tom what comedy half the line sorry
about the tail has a mind of its own
Spaceballs clothes it's actually space
balls not pants baseballs but I'll give
you the points anyway Ryan in the Lord
of the Rings films what characters said
I'm altogether not a name one side
because no one is all together on my
side Silent Bob
you have no idea how disappointing it is
not to hear pop I say Treebeard can you
just say it to me maybe I'll give you
the points no you had your chance
Treebeard nope you had your chance now
you're just mocking me Tom in The Big
Lebowski which character said I mean say
what you like about the tenets of
National Socialism dude at least it's an
ethos Walker so check yes why given
though the last name I am so sad having
you lose because you didn't know about
Kentucky Fried movie ok Ryan what sports
movie starring Kurt Russell had the line
if we play them 10 times they might win
9 but not this game Bob Arum no it's
miracle which you're gonna need now to
get out of this Durham I'm liking you
again Tom you're a good friend
you like Kentucky Fried movie Tom finish
this line from Full Metal Jacket this is
my rifle this is my gun this is for
shooting this is for fun and you're
completing that line right you're not
just telling me right now something
personal about you know I don't know
rope in my car but that's nothing to do
with guns of course not god I am so glad
I got to you before you know it is this
is for fighting this is for fun which I
know much about both Ryan in which movie
did Humphrey Bogart's say it's the stuff
dreams are made of The Maltese Falcon
yes Tom what Western comedy had the line
do you know what a plethora is the three
amigos close it's the three amigos not
yeah the three amigos it's a funny line
it is a funny line but nevertheless you
should keep your mind in the game you
have no idea how far you're trailing
behind right now Tom well you're as
drunk as I am how we can talk now I'm
seeing how I got the
Ryan in what older Disney film did Sean
Connery asked what kind of man doesn't
believe in the little people
fatal attraction yes and he sings in it
it's amazing that is a no by God just
the image of Sean Connery in fatal
attraction Walt Disney's fatal
attraction well Disney's fatal
attraction you know what I'm giving you
ten points for that simply because I
think we should make Walt Disney's they
don't traction with Sean Connery singing
I like this idea you're gonna be on
board if you win this round if not I'll
just get your corpse on there somewhere
Tom what classic film noir had the line
I am big it's the pictures that got
small Alice in Wonderland after she ate
the cookie no no bigger no yeah I know
it's clever but it isn't funny I
expected more out of your Tom no that's
pretty much my life yeah Wow and you're
sad and you're bringing me in a bad mood
shut up Ryan what TV character was
famous for asking just one more question
Columbo very good yes Tom what movie
series features the phrase that can only
be one commander yeah they're sure to
only been beautiful beautiful that's all
I got going oh and that is the buzzer we
are out of time damn it it looks like
Tom won I am so tempted right now to
give all the points to Ryan and have him
win but honestly being president the
Popeye fan club he is more likely to
kill me so I'm still gonna have you
winter drag him off that's right drag
Ryan off it was a good good attempt off
you go then
Wow he um he's really gonna die thinks
you think right tom
no not really I like you again we'll be
right back with the final round where
Tom goes up against me if you would like
to be a contestant a pop quiz hotshot
and live in the Chicagoland area send a
video via YouTube stating your name 8
and why you think it would be a good
contestant
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Tom
congratulations you'll be battling
against nostalgia critic on our final
round I'll be reading off seven
questions whoever answers the most
questions correctly will win the game
whoever doesn't well we'll see Tom if
you win you'll be able to get this a new
car model that you can build yourself
all assembly required as well as a
hundred dollars in cash and of course
you're live very good
today's theme is Star Wars quotes I'll
be reading off two quotes and you will
identify the character I'll start off
with you Tom Tom in my experience
there's no such thing as luck I'm solo
incorrect critic you want other targets
a military target name the system peter
cushing that's incorrect
Tom Yoda you seek Yoda Yoda correct
critic I've been waiting for you obi-wan
we meet again at last that's eight
correct
Tom this deal is getting worse all the
time Lando Calrissian correct critic now
young Skywalker you will die
the Emperor correct Tom many Bothans
died to bring us this information man ma
correct critic it's a trap fish guy uh
dinner I fuck no I'm sorry it's Admiral
Ackbar ah Tom Luke saw a farmer Owen he
has too much was father at him and Peru
correct critic would somebody get this
big walking carpet out of my way
Princess Leia correct Tom it's against
our programming to impersonate a deity
c-3po correct and critic he's no good to
me dead puppet correct and the winner is
nicely done town nicely done you walk
out of here with your life but on the
plus side on that to see your wife
tonight so I don't know how long it's
gonna last and I would say don't tell
anyone in the police but on the plus
side I think the police are gonna be
looking for you soon anyway we are now
friends forever and ever and ever and I
will find you if you tell anybody about
this nevertheless we will see you next
time on pop quiz hotshot boy we had a
lot of fun here today didn't we general
anaesthetic we did indeed yeah you know
I always find those parts where they
talk at the end like with you know cats
a showgirl or whatever just really
really awkward so I'm really glad we're
not doing that absolutely not at all
nope you're definitely not a showgirl
nope nope not anymore anyway really yeah
I'm finding out so much about you indeed
with that figure you were a showgirl
right yes it doesn't shock me they used
to be a woman but with that figure that
really fascinates me there is a niche
for me really yes and obviously you have
found that yes is it a niche with the
leash by any chance not only on
alternate Saturdays okay because I like
that stuff myself
indeed can't fight No